und wir begrüßen hier im Studio Bild
meinungschef Philipp piathoff jetzt mit
den Themen über die Deutschland heute
früh spricht und eines davon philipp ist
eine bisschen seltsame Löschaktion von
Youtube was hat es damit auf sich ganz
genau also wir haben gestern erfahren
und auch berichtet dass YouTube die
Videoplattform mehrere Videos der
künstleraktion alles auf den Tisch
gelöscht hat da sind diese
Künstlervideos Interviews mit
regierungskritischen zum Teil sehr
renommierten corona-experten die eine
Künstlergruppe um Volker Bruch Wotan
Wilke Möhring und so weiter
veröffentlicht hat um sich mit dem zu
beschäftigen die ihrer Meinung nach in
der corona-krise zu kurz kam und da
wurde auch über Meinungsfreiheit
gesprochen der wurde über die Fehler in
der Inzidenz gesprochen und youtube hat
jetzt drei Videos mindestens einfach
gelöscht und das hat auch Auswirkungen
auf den auf die Zukunft dieses
youtube-kanals 7 Tage lang darf dort
gerade erst mal hochgeladen werden
übrigens auch nicht das neue Video das
Interview mit der ehemaligen
Familienministerin Kristina Schröder
also dieses Video kann jetzt tagelang
nicht hochgeladen werden weil dieser
Kanal mit dieser Art Sperre belegt wurde
Youtube Begründung für diese Sperre
Philipp ja das ist total abstrakt also
Youtube sagt da wird angeblich gegen
irgendwelche Standards verstoßen da wird
etwas über Schutzimpfung gegen covid
behaupte behauptet was aber nicht im
Einklang zu bringen sei mit der WHO und
aber es wird nicht klar also ich habe
Youtube gestern angefragt und habe nach
Klartext verlangt und gefragt was ist es
denn konkret welche Aussage ist es denn
konkret an der sie sich stören und da
kam bislang nichts zurück auch die
Künstler wissen nicht warum diese Videos
gelöscht wurden sie sprechen davon dass
ihre dass sie einfach stumm geschaltet
werden und gehen jetzt auch mit dem
Top-Anwalt Joachim Steinhöfel der
wirklich Experte ist und meinungsfotos
in diesem Video
im Gespräch der geht jetzt gegen Youtube
vor und ist da auch relativ
zuversichtlich ich habe gestern mit ihm
gesprochen er hat mir gesagt er ist
absolut fassungslos das ist eine ganz
neue Dimension das hier einfach wirklich
Interviews mit mit Experten zum Beispiel
mit mit einem Mathematik
Mathematikprofessor aus Leipzig der über
Inzidenz gesprochen hat der glasklar
aufgezeigt hat wurde die Fehler in der
Berechnung lagen also wirklich absolut
harmlose Interviews hier einfach
gestrichen werden du hast eher
stundenlang diese Videos hier angeschaut
auch genau geguckt was da drin steckt
wie provokant das ist ob da irgendwelche
falschen Fakten drin sind und so hast du
irgendwas gefunden was gefährlich ist
was eine Löschaktion eventuell eben doch
rechtfertigt nein also ehrlich gesagt
ich konnte natürlich kein Faktencheck
machen aber ein falscher fakt ist für
mich noch keine Grundlage für eine
Löschung ich glaube wenn man anfängt da
so drauf zu schauen wie was könnte man
was könnte eventuell nicht ganz richtig
sein ja gut da kann ich youtube aber
ganze Liste voller Videos schicken und
zwar auch von der Bundesregierung auch
von Karl Lauterbach auch von Jens Spahn
und von Christian Drosten und wirklich
von allen aber youtube ist ja keine
Faktencheck Plattform keine
Wahrheitskommission die jetzt
entscheidet was nun richtig und was
falsch ist und man kann über viele Dinge
das sieht man bei Youtube vielleicht
nicht so einfach auch unterschiedlicher
Meinung sein und das wäre toll immer
würde Diskussion ist sowas immer ganz
praktisch denken unterschiedlicher
Meinung zu sein gar nicht mal so
schlecht und ich frag mich wenn ich so
Interviews sehe mit wirklich
renommierten Experten und dann kommt
YouTube und löscht das wer ist denn
youtube ist das eine Universität ist das
ein Virologen Gremium das da sitzt sich
diese Youtube Videos alle anschaut und
sagt mir aber das dieses eine von den
100 Millionen die heute hochgeladen
wurden das Löschen ganz kurz Philipp
also lieber Herr Youtube wenn sie uns
zuhören heute melden Sie sich derjenige
der das alles gelöscht hat jetzt wer hat
sich damit beschäftigt wer hat das
gelöscht melden sich einfach bei uns wir
können hier diskuss diskutieren im
Studio gerne herzlich vielleicht für
morgen früh für morgen Vormittag wir
eingeladen die Herren von Damen
natürlich von Youtube für eine bunte
Diskussion über Meinungsvielfalt hier in
Deutschland und im Netz gegeben
[Musik]